This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a common complaint that people don't read books anymore. But the truth is, print book sales are up these days. Since 2013, sales of physical books have increased every year. At first, people attributed this to the rise of adult coloring books, but even as their popularity has dwindled, book sales have risen. I'm talking about physical, old-fashioned books with paper pages full of words. We love them.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。人们不再读书了，这是一种常见的抱怨。但事实是，如今纸质书的销量正在上升。自2013年以来，实体书的销量每年都在增长。起初，人们将其归因于成人涂色书的兴起，但即使在涂色书热度减退后，图书销量依然在上涨。我说的是那种有纸质书页、写满文字的、老派的实体书。我们热爱它们。
The great Argentinian writer Jorge Luis Borges once said, I cannot sleep unless I am surrounded by books. And I kind of agree. That's reporter Pierce Gully, although he's not normally a reporter. I'm a graduate student in creative writing, and for the past two years, I've taught fiction writing to undergrads at the University of Virginia. I assign a lot of reading, but mostly it's in the form of photocopied pages.
伟大的阿根廷作家豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯曾说：“除非被书环绕，否则我无法入睡。”我对此深有同感。那是记者皮尔斯·格利，尽管他通常不是记者。“我是创意写作专业的研究生，过去两年里，我一直在弗吉尼亚大学教本科生小说写作。我布置了很多阅读任务，但大多是以复印件的形式。”
Don't worry, the print shop pays for the rights. I don't want to force my students to buy too much, but I always make sure I assign at least one physical book, and I always try to pick something that's beautiful, one with a nice font, a lovely page design, a pleasing paper grain, and an intriguing cover. Don't get me wrong, the words inside matter too. But I think it's important for my students to have
别担心，印刷店支付了版权费。我不想强迫学生买太多书，但我总是确保至少布置一本实体书，而且我总是尽量挑选那些精美的书——字体优美、页面设计精良、纸张纹理舒适、封面引人入胜。别误会，书里的内容也很重要。但我认为，让学生拥有
an object that accentuates the pleasure of the physical act of reading and something they would hold on to after the class it ended. I personally toss hundreds of pages of radio scripts in the recycling bin every month, but I would have a really hard time throwing away a book. Once the pages have a spine, it's like they have a soul. It would feel wrong like you're spitting on knowledge itself. It's so hard to get rid of books. This is a story about books and, brace yourself, how to get rid of them.
一件能提升阅读这种身体行为乐趣的物品，并且在课程结束后他们仍会珍藏的东西，这很重要。我个人每个月都会把数百页的广播稿扔进回收箱，但我很难扔掉一本书。一旦书页有了书脊，它们就像有了灵魂。扔掉它会感觉不对劲，就像在亵渎知识本身。书真的很难处理。这是一个关于书的故事，而且，做好心理准备，这是一个关于如何处理掉它们的故事。
And in the words of REM, it starts with an earthquake. Downtown San Francisco in the background and we zoom into Candlestick Park. It was the most Bay Area sporting event imaginable. The Oakland A's were playing the San Francisco Giants in the 1989 World Series. Coming into the third game, on October 17th, 1989, the A's were in the lead. They had won the first two games. But just as the third game was about to kick off. I'll tell you what, we're having a nerd.
用REM乐队的话说，一切始于一场地震。背景是旧金山市中心，镜头拉近到烛台公园。那是你能想象到的最典型的湾区体育赛事。1989年世界大赛，奥克兰运动家队对阵旧金山巨人队。1989年10月17日，第三场比赛即将开始，运动家队处于领先地位。他们已经赢了前两场。但就在第三场比赛即将开球时……我告诉你吧，我们遇到麻烦了。
The TV broadcast cut out. When the signal came back, it was no longer a baseball game. This is Cheryl Jennings in the Channel 7 Newsroom. As you may have noticed, our power was knocked out. These were the early minutes of the Loma Prieta earthquake, which struck near Santa Cruz. This was the first major earthquake ever to be broadcast live on national TV. We have a report of a person trapped in an elevator in Shelter Bay. Part of the Bay Bridge had been destroyed.
电视转播中断了。当信号恢复时，那不再是一场棒球比赛。这是第七频道的谢丽尔·詹宁斯在新闻编辑室。“正如你们可能注意到的，我们的电力中断了。”这是洛马普里塔地震发生的最初几分钟，震中位于圣克鲁斯附近。这是有史以来第一次在全国电视上直播的大地震。“我们收到报告说有人被困在谢尔特湾的一部电梯里。海湾大桥的一部分已经损毁。”
There were fires, fallen buildings, widespread. spread power outages. In all, there were 63 deaths and almost 4,000 injuries. But this is a story about what happened to the San Francisco Public Library after this earthquake and because of this earthquake. The library suffered a lot of damage, especially on the higher floors. That's the one of the things about an earthquake is the effect of it is intensified the higher up you go. On the upper levels of the library, floors had caved in. Jason Gibbs was a new librarian there, but he couldn't go to work for two months after the quake. It was too dangerous. He says
到处都是火灾、倒塌的建筑物和大规模停电。总共有63人死亡，近4000人受伤。但这是一个关于旧金山公共图书馆在地震后以及因为这场地震而发生的故事。图书馆遭受了严重破坏，尤其是在高层。地震的一个特点是，楼层越高，影响越强烈。在图书馆的上层，地板已经塌陷。杰森·吉布斯当时是那里的一名新馆员，但地震后他有两个月无法去上班。太危险了。他说
bookshelves had collapsed sideways or fallen on their faces, and books lay in piles everywhere. Like the books had been tossed around by some angry force. No one was injured at the San Francisco Public Library, but the earthquake dumped half a million books on the floor. Even after two months of repairs, the post-earthquake situation in the San Francisco Public Library was still pretty bad. Library management determined that the stacks weren't safe and designated a new room for public browsing. Librarians curated a selection of books that they thought the public would most like to read, and those books went in that room. But they realized along the way that not every book was going to fit. In other words, even this winnowed down selection of books was too large for the available space.
书架侧向倒塌或正面着地，书本散落得到处都是。就像书被某种愤怒的力量随意抛掷一样。旧金山公共图书馆没有人受伤，但地震将五十万本书震到了地板上。即使经过两个月的维修，旧金山公共图书馆地震后的情况依然很糟糕。图书馆管理层认定书库不再安全，并指定了一个新房间供公众浏览。馆员们挑选了一批他们认为公众最想读的书，放进了那个房间。但他们后来意识到，并不是所有的书都能放进去。换句话说，即使是这批精选出来的书，对于现有空间来说也太大了。
They needed to winnow it down even more. The earthquake just happened. We don't have this shelving anymore. We need to make space. That's a reasonable thing to do if you approach it in a thoughtful way. Because libraries do get rid of books all the time. Earthquake or not. Put simply, there are so many new books coming in every day and only a finite amount of library space. The practice of freeing up library space is called weeding. If you think about it, it sounds ugly, but it is a really good description. description. That's Sharon McKellar. She supervises teen services at the Oakland Public Library.
他们需要进一步精简。地震刚刚发生。我们没有这些书架了。我们需要腾出空间。如果你以深思熟虑的方式处理，这是合理的做法。因为图书馆一直在清理书籍，无论是否发生地震。简单来说，每天都有这么多新书进来，而图书馆的空间是有限的。这种腾出图书馆空间的行为被称为“剔旧”（weeding）。如果你仔细想想，这个词听起来很难听，但它确实是一个非常贴切的描述。那是莎伦·麦凯勒。她是奥克兰公共图书馆青少年服务部的负责人。
Avery Truffleman went down the street to visit her and see how she weeds. You have to weed your garden for like the flowers to grow. I'm not a gardener. And weeding is not just about holding the book in your hands and asking yourself if that book sparks joy. There's really, really specific guidelines. We're not just randomly grabbing books out the shelf and putting them in the trash. McKellar and many other librarians at libraries all over the world weed their shelf. Weed their shelf. using the same set of guidelines. And it has an excellent acronym. Musty.
艾弗里·特鲁夫曼去街上拜访她，看看她是如何剔旧的。“你必须修剪花园，花儿才能生长。”我不是园丁。剔旧不仅仅是把书拿在手里，问自己这本书是否能带来快乐。这有非常、非常具体的指导方针。我们不是随意从书架上抓书扔进垃圾桶。麦凯勒和世界各地图书馆的许多其他馆员都在使用同一套指导方针来剔旧。而且它有一个很棒的缩写：MUSTY。
M-U-S-T-Y. M is for misleading. Or factually inaccurate. U is for ugly. This one's a little ugly. It's like the cover is a little broken. Isn't the fact that it's so beat up an indication that it was loved?
M-U-S-T-Y。M代表误导（Misleading），或者事实不准确。U代表丑陋（Ugly）。这一本有点丑。就像封面有点破损。难道它破旧不堪不正说明它曾被人们喜爱吗？
For sure. So if it's been checked out in the last three years, I'd probably actually buy a new copy of it. If it hasn't been checked out in the last three years, I would probably consider it for withdrawal. S for superseded. Buy a new edition or a much better book. This would be like an old manual for Windows 98 or an outdated travel guide.
当然。所以如果它在过去三年里被借阅过，我可能会买一本新的。如果过去三年没被借阅过，我可能会考虑将其撤架。S代表被取代（Superseded）。购买新版本或更好的书。这就像是一本旧的Windows 98手册或过时的旅游指南。
These are the kinds of books that get shredded. And the last two letters are T for Trivial and Y for your collection has no use for this book, because they really want that musty acronym to work. Those last two, the T and the Y, trivial, and your library has no need for this book, these are the tricky ones. They're not necessarily statements of fact. They're judgments of value. What's trivial to me might be very important to you,
这些书会被粉碎。最后两个字母是T代表琐碎（Trivial），Y代表你的馆藏不需要这本书（Your collection has no use for this book），因为他们真的想让MUSTY这个缩写成立。最后两个，T和Y，琐碎和你的图书馆不需要这本书，这些是棘手的。它们不一定是事实陈述，而是价值判断。对我来说琐碎的东西，对你来说可能非常重要，
and vice versa. But even here, these judgment calls are made by librarians who specialize in the relevant section, based on circulation statistics. You just have to trust that your librarians are doing their best for the public. We want to be able to keep bringing you the most relevant, most current information, and the only way to do that is by having room to do it. So the only way we can do that is by sometimes withdrawing the things that are not as useful anymore. Although some sections, according to the library guidelines, are generally self-weeding. In other words, they disappear. Oh, people steal them.
反之亦然。但即使在这里，这些判断也是由专门负责相关部门的馆员根据流通统计数据做出的。你只需要相信你的馆员正在为公众尽最大努力。我们希望能够继续为您提供最相关、最新的信息，而做到这一点的唯一方法就是有空间。所以我们能做的唯一方法就是有时撤掉那些不再那么有用的东西。尽管根据图书馆指南，某些部分通常是“自动剔旧”的。换句话说，它们消失了。哦，人们偷走了它们。
Yeah, certain sections of the library tend to disappear more than others. Books about marijuana, the Bible, and the occult are probably the biggest ones I can think of. But for the sections that do have to get weeded, weeding is generally a touchy subject. The reason why is probably already clear to you. People don't like the idea of books being thrown away. We like books, a lot, and perhaps no one loves books more than librarians. There's a part of you that just winces every time you have to remove a book. I mean, books are dear to us.
是的，图书馆的某些部分往往比其他部分更容易消失。关于大麻、圣经和神秘学的书可能是我能想到的最大的几类。但对于那些确实需要剔旧的部分，剔旧通常是一个敏感的话题。原因你可能已经很清楚了。人们不喜欢书被扔掉的想法。我们非常喜欢书，也许没有人比馆员更爱书了。你内心深处有一部分，每次不得不移除一本书时都会感到痛苦。我的意思是，书对我们来说很珍贵。
Part of my maturing as a librarian is to get over that a little bit. Yes, weeding is normal and necessary. But after the 1989 earthquake, the San Francisco Public Library started weeding an unusual amount of books. The librarians were told to move quickly, and they didn't use musty, or any sort of comparable system. The librarians were ordered to go through each collection, book by book, and insert a slip of paper into each. Green, yellow, and red. Green meant the book had been checked out that year.
作为一名馆员，我成熟的一部分就是稍微克服这一点。是的，剔旧是正常且必要的。但在1989年地震后，旧金山公共图书馆开始剔除数量异常多的书籍。馆员们被告知要迅速行动，他们没有使用MUSTY或任何类似的系统。馆员们被要求逐本检查每项馆藏，并在每本书中插入一张纸条。绿色、黄色和红色。绿色意味着这本书当年被借阅过。
Yellow meant the book had been checked out in the last two years. And red meant that it had been over two years since somebody had checked out that book. And the red books were the ones that were in potential danger. Danger because management had decided that the red books had to go. Compared to the careful consideration of Mustie, the system of the green, yellow and red cards is a rather blunt instrument. It's certainly not the only measure whether somebody has borrowed it within the
黄色意味着这本书在过去两年内被借阅过，红色意味着距离上次借阅已经超过两年了。红色的书是处于潜在危险中的书。危险是因为管理层决定必须处理掉红色的书。与MUSTY的仔细考量相比，红黄绿卡系统是一个相当生硬的工具。这当然不是衡量某人是否在最近一段时间内借阅过的唯一标准。
last period of time. It felt rather arbitrary. And it wasn't really clear where the red card books were going to go or if they would ever be used again. In Jason Gibbs's department, for example, the art and music collection, the discarded books got sent to an abandoned hospital owned by the
这感觉相当武断。而且并不清楚红卡书要去哪里，或者它们是否还会被再次使用。例如，在杰森·吉布斯的部门，即艺术和音乐馆藏，被丢弃的书被送往城市拥有的一家废弃医院，
city because there was nowhere else to put them. Even battle-hardened librarians like Gibbs felt that the weeding was happening too fast. You had librarians in different sections weeding furiously and not really communicating with each other. As a consequence, lots and lots of books were removed from the library. And no one quite knew how many, because no one was keeping track. It was ultimately, I think, a weakness of management from the top. Jason Gibbs is a pretty even-keeled guy,
因为没有其他地方可以放它们。即使是像吉布斯这样久经沙场的馆员也觉得剔旧进行得太快了。不同部门的馆员在疯狂地剔旧，彼此之间并没有真正的沟通。结果，大量书籍被从图书馆移除。没有人确切知道有多少，因为没有人进行记录。我认为这最终是管理层从上层开始的软弱。杰森·吉布斯是一个相当冷静的人，
but that's his diplomatic way of saying that the problems began with the head librarian at that time, a man named Kenneth Dowlin. Let me hear a two. you could be visiting the public library without leaving your home. In the years leading up to the 1989 earthquake, the San Francisco Public Library was starting to rethink its whole approach to books in light of a new little thing called the Internet. Imagine plugging a computer like this one into any telephone in the world
但这只是他外交辞令，意思是问题始于当时的首席馆员，一个叫肯尼斯·道林的人。让我听听……你可以在不离开家的情况下参观公共图书馆。在1989年地震前的几年里，旧金山公共图书馆开始根据一种叫“互联网”的新事物，重新思考其对待书籍的整体方式。想象一下，把像这样的电脑插入世界上的任何电话，
and being able to search any library in the world. And a big part of this pivot was when, in 1987, San Francisco hired Kenneth Dowlin as its new city-like. librarian. As San Francisco's city librarian, Ken Dowling must make sure that two million people have access to 18 million books and other information on a limited budget. Dowling was all about the internet. He had recently published a book called The Electronic Library, in which he argued that technology was changing the way people used information, and therefore changing the role of librarians. This is a clip of it.
就能搜索世界上的任何图书馆。而这一转变的重要部分是，1987年，旧金山聘请了肯尼斯·道林作为新的城市馆员。作为旧金山的城市馆员，肯·道林必须确保两百万人能在有限的预算内获取一千八百万本书和其他信息。道林全心全意拥抱互联网。他最近出版了一本书叫《电子图书馆》，他在书中主张技术正在改变人们使用信息的方式，从而改变了馆员的角色。这是其中的一段剪辑。
The internet web world, if you will, collapses time, collapses distance. and is collapsing cost. If this sounds unremarkable, not to mention a bit quaint, keep in mind that Dowlin was saying all this stuff as early as 1984. He certainly understood at an early stage what the Internet was going to do for communication. But there was a flip side to Dowland's visionary concept
互联网网络世界，如果你愿意的话，压缩了时间，压缩了距离，并且正在压缩成本。如果这听起来平淡无奇，更不用说有点古雅了，请记住道林早在1984年就说了这些话。他确实在早期就理解了互联网将为通信带来什么。但道林关于数字化网络图书馆的愿景概念也有另一面。
of digitally networked libraries. Some people felt that Dowlin had a distressing lack of concern for books. There was a sense that when it came to the physical collections, he just didn't have any interest. Dowlam was also overseeing the design of a new main library for the city of San Francisco, which would complete his vision of the library of the future. The city is building a new $100 million library that is wired for computers as well as television. This new library would have twice as much space as the old one, but a big chunk of that space
有些人觉得道林对书籍缺乏令人不安的关心。有一种感觉是，当涉及到实体馆藏时，他根本没有任何兴趣。道林还在监督旧金山新总馆的设计，这将完成他关于未来图书馆的愿景。“这座城市正在建造一座耗资1亿美元的新图书馆，它不仅有电脑，还有电视。”这座新图书馆的空间将是旧图书馆的两倍，但其中很大一部分空间
wasn't going to be for shelving books. Instead, much of the library's interior was devoted to an atrium in the middle of the building, which would rise 86 feet to a conical glass roof. Lots of librarians worried that this big, empty atrium wouldn't leave a lot of space for books. The atrium was evidence that books were not the sole priority of this building, and Dallan wasn't going to let a good crisis go to waste. The earthquake was a perfect excuse to do what he wanted to do anyway. Shrinked the physical collection before the move to the new space. Dowland's administration started sending books to landfills.
不会用于存放书籍。相反，图书馆内部的大部分空间都用于建筑中间的一个中庭，它将上升86英尺，通向一个圆锥形的玻璃屋顶。许多馆员担心这个巨大的空旷中庭不会给书籍留下太多空间。中庭证明了书籍并不是这座建筑的唯一优先事项，而道林不会让一场好的危机被浪费掉。地震是一个完美的借口，可以做他无论如何都想做的事情：在搬迁到新空间之前缩小实体馆藏。道林的政府开始把书送到垃圾填埋场。
In the days after the quake, books are being sent out by the truckload, several times a week. This is not normal library practice. 27 librarians signed a petition asking Kenneth Dowland for the weeding to stop. But that didn't work. So Jason Gibbs and his colleagues decided to do something. In any institution, you have a variety of people. There are some people who will just kind of do whatever they're told. and then there are other people who feel like they have a higher calling to the profession.
地震后的几天里，书本每周几次被卡车运走。这不是正常的图书馆做法。27名馆员签署了一份请愿书，要求肯尼斯·道林停止剔旧。但这没用。所以杰森·吉布斯和他的同事决定做点什么。在任何机构里，你都有各种各样的人。有些人只会听命行事，而另一些人则觉得他们对职业有一种更高的使命感。
Gibbs and librarians from several other departments felt that higher calling. They banded together and called themselves the guerrilla librarians. Guerrilla like the freedom fighter. Fighting for the freedom to not put little slips of red paper on books against the orders of management. Let's just say that we did not withdraw books because they hadn't circulated. We generally held on to the collection. Jason says that other guerrilla librarians snuck into the stacks and replaced red slips with green ones,
吉布斯和其他几个部门的馆员感受到了那种更高的使命感。他们联合起来，自称为“游击队馆员”。游击队就像自由战士。为了不把红色小纸条贴在书上而抗争，违抗管理层的命令。“我们直说吧，我们没有因为书没有流通就撤架。我们通常会保留馆藏。”杰森说，其他游击队馆员偷偷溜进书库，用绿色纸条替换了红色纸条，
thereby designating the book as a circulating book and keeping it in the collection. The guerrilla librarians wanted to determine exactly how many books had been weeded and how many had been dumped, but nobody had any idea how many books were being taken away. And there was a risk that they'd never be able to find out the magnitude of this massive clearing.
从而将该书指定为流通书籍并将其保留在馆藏中。游击队馆员想确定到底有多少书被剔除，有多少被倾倒，但没有人知道有多少书被带走了。而且存在一种风险，他们可能永远无法发现这次大规模清理的规模。
Because Kenneth Dallan decided to get really, rid of the physical card catalog, those files full of index cards chronicling each book. The card catalog is an artifact, but I will not support the view that the card catalog is a working technology to help people find books anymore. It is not, and most of the libraries in the world know that and have moved on. He was right about this. Already at that point, more than 90 percent of the nation's libraries had computerized their card catalogs. The earthquake itself allowed the San Francisco Public Library to modernize their catalog. With a disaster relief money they were granted, the library was able to get electronic
因为肯尼斯·道林决定彻底摆脱实体卡片目录，那些装满索引卡、记录每本书的文件。卡片目录是一件文物，但我不再支持卡片目录是帮助人们查找书籍的有效技术的观点。它不是，世界上大多数图书馆都知道这一点，并且已经向前看了。他在这一点上是对的。当时，全国超过90%的图书馆已经将卡片目录计算机化了。地震本身使旧金山公共图书馆能够实现目录现代化。利用获得的救灾资金，图书馆能够获得电子
catalog software. So now, logically, Dallin wanted to get rid of the physical card catalog, which the library had stopped updating in 1991. San Francisco's old card catalog was not moved to the new library. It is locked up and inaccessible to the public. But this move, to get rid of the old card catalog, caused a surprisingly intense outcry from the guerrilla librarians. And it wasn't just a matter of nostalgia or personal preference. The physical card catalog said exactly what was in the library before all the arbitrary weeding. If a book was red-tagged and weeded, it wouldn't be registered in the new digital system. There would be no record it had ever existed at all. And so the old card catalog
目录软件。所以现在，从逻辑上讲，道林想摆脱实体卡片目录，图书馆在1991年就停止了更新。旧金山的旧卡片目录没有搬到新图书馆。它被锁起来，公众无法访问。但这一摆脱旧卡片目录的举动，引起了游击队馆员出人意料的强烈抗议。这不仅仅是怀旧或个人偏好的问题。实体卡片目录准确地说明了在所有武断的剔旧之前，图书馆里有什么。如果一本书被贴上红标签并被剔除，它就不会在新的数字系统中注册。根本不会有它曾经存在过的记录。所以旧卡片目录
was more than just a card catalog. The card catalog is evidence. Evidence of a purred. To get to the card catalog, the librarians pulled out their secret weapon, Nicholson Baker. I'm Nicholson Baker, and I am a writer of books, fiction, nonfiction, and I became, for a brief period of time, a library activist. Baker is a writer of novels and essays that celebrate the minutia of daily life. And in 1994, Baker had gotten national attention for a New Yorker article about the disposal of physical card catalogs. A practice that had become increasingly common
不仅仅是卡片目录。卡片目录是证据。一段时期的证据。为了接触到卡片目录，馆员们拿出了他们的秘密武器：尼科尔森·贝克。“我是尼科尔森·贝克，我是小说、非虚构作品的作家，我曾短暂地成为一名图书馆活动家。”贝克是一位赞美日常生活细节的小说和散文作家。1994年，贝克因一篇关于处理实体卡片目录的《纽约客》文章而受到全国关注。这种做法变得越来越普遍，
and which upset Baker a lot. The San Francisco Public Library had a very ornate, beautiful card catalog. That feeling that you have when your fingers would dance over the little cardboard pieces and you could tell a subject that was popular because the tops were darker and there's all sorts of tricks that were just fun.
这让贝克非常不安。“旧金山公共图书馆有一个非常华丽、漂亮的卡片目录。那种感觉，当你的手指在小纸片上跳舞时，你可以分辨出哪个主题很受欢迎，因为顶部颜色更深，还有各种各样有趣的技巧。”
The guerrilla librarians reached out to Baker for help. By now, it was 1996. and the new library was nearing completion. The lost books, evidenced only by their locked-away card catalog, were teetering on the edge of disregard. In their email to Nicholson Baker, the librarians wrote, You are the only one who can save it now.
游击队馆员向贝克寻求帮助。到那时已经是1996年了，新图书馆即将完工。那些丢失的书籍，只有被锁起来的卡片目录作为证据，正处于被忽视的边缘。在给尼科尔森·贝克的电子邮件中，馆员们写道：“你是现在唯一能拯救它的人。”
Part of me thought, oh God, this is going to get complicated. Oh, it would. At the time, Baker was living just across the bay in Berkeley. So he made a formal request to inspect the card catalog. Kenneth Dallon denied that request. So Baker sued the library for access to the card catalog. Never sue anything if you can avoid it and don't sue a library. This lawsuit took a while and it was a bit of a mess,
“我的一部分心想，天哪，这会变得很复杂。”确实如此。当时，贝克住在海湾对面的伯克利。所以他正式申请检查卡片目录。肯尼斯·道林拒绝了该请求。所以贝克起诉图书馆以获取卡片目录。“如果能避免，永远不要起诉任何东西，也不要起诉图书馆。”这场诉讼花了一段时间，而且有点混乱，
but it automatically classified the card catalog as a public document. Now the library had to keep it. And then Baker and the guerrilla librarians got to work in secret. And you can imagine this with kind of Mission Impossible music going. Yes, please. The guerrilla librarians snuck into off-limits areas in the library. They took away books that were going to be destroyed. In other words, they stole them.
但它自动将卡片目录归类为公共文件。现在图书馆必须保留它。然后贝克和游击队馆员秘密行动起来。你可以想象这伴随着某种《碟中谍》的音乐。“是的，请。”游击队馆员溜进了图书馆的禁区。他们带走了即将被销毁的书籍。换句话说，他们偷了它们。
The guerrillas stockpiled hundreds and hundreds of library discards, in their homes, in their cars, and their offices, in lockers, and boxes, all in the hope that they would someday be returned to the library. Nicholson Baker stole books, too. I was driving back and forth across the Bay Bridge with my car full of books. that I had actually found in this place that was the deselection room. Baker ignored the staff-only signs and walked right into the deselection room, the basement storage, all the places where the SFPL were storing books.
游击队员在他们的家中、车里、办公室、储物柜和盒子里囤积了数百本图书馆丢弃的书籍，所有这些都是为了希望有一天它们能被归还给图书馆。尼科尔森·贝克也偷了书。“我开着车在海湾大桥上来回穿梭，车里装满了书，我实际上是在那个被称为‘剔除室’的地方找到的。”贝克无视“仅限员工”的标志，直接走进剔除室、地下室仓库，所有旧金山公共图书馆存放书籍的地方。
He picked up a bunch of books that had no match in the online catalog and found some real treasures. They had stored all these, you know, including 17th century, very valuable books and stuff was down there. Baker, along with a historian, began comparing the online catalog to the physical. card catalog. As they cross-referenced the two lists, it turned out that a lot of books were missing, way more than anyone had expected. Let me tell you, what an opening day celebration today. At last, in April of 1996, the new main library opened its doors, with Panash. Talk about fanfare, nothing less than a parachute jump into Civic Center, with the man holding the symbolic key to the new library. And in May of 1996,
他捡起了一堆在在线目录中没有匹配项的书，并发现了一些真正的宝藏。“他们把所有这些都存起来了，你知道，包括17世纪非常有价值的书籍，东西就在下面。”贝克和一位历史学家开始比较在线目录和实体卡片目录。当他们交叉引用这两个列表时，结果发现很多书不见了，比任何人预期的都要多。“让我告诉你，今天的开幕日庆祝活动真是太棒了。”终于，在1996年4月，新总馆敞开了大门，气派十足。谈到盛况，没有什么比跳伞进入市政中心，由那个人拿着新图书馆的象征性钥匙更壮观的了。而在1996年5月，
About a month after the library opened, the guerrilla librarians organized an event in the library auditorium where Baker delivered a speech stating what he had found. Baker contended that Dowlin was responsible for a massive destruction of books, the systematic removal to a landfill of at least 200,000 volumes. And I just said it right there in the library itself, in a talk, and I think it really startled people. The phrase that got Baker,
在图书馆开放大约一个月后，游击队馆员在图书馆礼堂组织了一场活动，贝克发表了演讲，陈述了他的发现。贝克认为道林应对大规模销毁书籍负责，即系统性地将至少20万册书籍运往垃圾填埋场。“我就在图书馆里说了出来，在一次演讲中，我想这真的让人们感到震惊。”让贝克获得
most attention, was when he called this mass disposal a, quote, hate crime directed at the past. This really upset library management. And it became this kind of minor dust-up in San Francisco. Word had begun to spread that Baker was writing another story for the New Yorker, one specifically about this whole weeding debacle. So the president of the library commission wrote to the New Yorker's editor at that time and attempted to kill the piece by discrediting Baker. It didn't work, and Baker's article,
最多关注的短语，是他称这种大规模处置为“针对过去的仇恨犯罪”。这让图书馆管理层非常不安。这在旧金山变成了一场小小的风波。有传言说贝克正在为《纽约客》写另一篇报道，专门关于整个剔旧惨败。所以图书馆委员会主席写信给当时的《纽约客》编辑，试图通过抹黑贝克来扼杀这篇文章。这没用，贝克的文章
came out in October of 1996. It was called The Author versus the Library. A current New Yorker article called it the Great Book Purge, claiming more than 100,000 rare and one-of-a-kind books were hauled to the dump. And then things got a little out of hand. The library hit back, condemning Baker for accusing them of a hate crime, and saying that he misunderstood the problem. They also tried to discredit him because of some bad math he had reported.
于1996年10月发表。题目是《作者与图书馆》。一篇当前的《纽约客》文章称其为“大书清洗”，声称超过10万本珍稀和孤本图书被运往垃圾场。然后事情有点失控了。图书馆进行了反击，谴责贝克指控他们犯有仇恨犯罪，并称他误解了问题。他们还试图通过他报道的一些错误数据来抹黑他。
It turns out one of the guerrilla librarians had messed up the measurements of the old library shelves. In fact, the new library had much more space for books than the old one. It was a very bad error. It was very embarrassing. Although it didn't change the fact that the library had taken so many books to the dump. Then both sides started lobbying insults at each other as the local and national press piled on. One paper compared Baker to the unit bomber. It was basically an analog Twitter feud.
事实证明，其中一名游击队馆员弄错了旧图书馆书架的测量数据。事实上，新图书馆的书籍空间比旧图书馆大得多。这是一个非常严重的错误。非常尴尬。尽管这并没有改变图书馆把这么多书扔进垃圾场的事实。然后双方开始互相辱骂，当地和全国媒体也加入进来。一家报纸将贝克比作“大学炸弹客”。这基本上是一场模拟的推特争吵。
I wasn't prepared to be part of it. I didn't know that I was getting into that, kind of a battle. It was really ugly. And even from guerrilla librarian Jason Gibbs' standpoint, the whole weeding controversy got a little blown out of proportion. It probably was not as horrible as Nicholson Baker made it out, but it was horrible enough. Meanwhile, the new library itself had already been built, and it was, judging from the influx of visitors, a success.
“我没准备好参与其中。我不知道我卷入了那种战斗。这真的很丑陋。”即使从游击队馆员杰森·吉布斯的角度来看，整个剔旧争议也有点被夸大了。“可能没有尼科尔森·贝克描述的那么可怕，但已经足够可怕了。”与此同时，新图书馆本身已经建成，从涌入的游客来看，它是一个成功。
As charges and counter charges fly, three times as many visitors, streamed through the doors of the new library, an indication that some book lovers welcome the change. Some of those books saved by the guerrilla librarians in boxes and lockers were transferred back into the collection. All the books in Jason Gibbs Department, Art and Music, made it back. But he says that many of the other books didn't. They stayed gone, and many of them probably got discarded.
随着指控和反指控的飞扬，三倍多的游客涌入新图书馆的大门，这表明一些爱书人士欢迎这种变化。游击队馆员在箱子和储物柜中保存的一些书籍被转回馆藏。杰森·吉布斯部门（艺术和音乐）的所有书籍都回来了。但他说，许多其他书籍没有回来。它们消失了，其中许多可能被丢弃了。
Nicholson Baker says he still has some of the books he stockpiled. Given the painful experience of the controversy, the library wasn't really interested in res shelving them. But at the end of the day, the controversy wasn't only about what to do with old books. It was a debate about what books are. Are they beautiful objects that we can smell and touch and collect? Or are they eternal sources of knowledge accessible to everyone in the ether? Well, and it's both.
尼科尔森·贝克说他仍然保留着他囤积的一些书。鉴于争议的痛苦经历，图书馆对重新上架它们并不感兴趣。但归根结底，争议不仅在于如何处理旧书。这是一场关于书是什么的辩论。它们是我们能闻、能摸、能收藏的美丽物体吗？还是它们是每个人都能在以太中获取的永恒知识源泉？嗯，两者都是。
In a given research quest, you and I might want to find out what is in a book in the fastest possible way. Well, nowadays, it's miraculous. Sometimes you want the words. Sometimes you want more than the words you want the words laid out on the page. Clearly, Nicholson Baker can see Dowland's perspective. But Baker maintains that we shouldn't give up on the printed page. His argument and the public battle around it in the 90s was a big reason why the San Francisco Public Library totally overhauled their collections policies.
在特定的研究任务中，你和我可能都想以最快的方式找出书里的内容。嗯，如今，这简直是奇迹。有时你想要文字。有时你想要的不仅仅是文字，你想要文字在页面上的排版。显然，尼科尔森·贝克能看到道林的观点。但贝克坚持认为我们不应该放弃印刷页面。他的论点以及90年代围绕它的公开斗争，是旧金山公共图书馆彻底改革其馆藏政策的一个重要原因。
They made it a policy that if a library branch is considering weeding a last copy of some book, they must send that copy to a subject specialist who will decide if it can be weeded or not. And for the books that do have to go, the San Francisco Public Library developed a community redistribution program to make sure the extra copies of popular books can live on somewhere else. We distribute them to schools and city colleges and prisons. And strangely enough, one of the biggest changes to the modern practice of weeding is something that Kenneth Dallin himself helped establish. online communication between libraries.
他们制定了一项政策：如果图书馆分馆考虑剔除某本书的最后一本副本，他们必须将其发送给主题专家，由专家决定是否可以剔除。对于那些确实必须处理掉的书，旧金山公共图书馆开发了一个社区再分配计划，以确保流行书籍的多余副本可以在其他地方继续存在。“我们将它们分发给学校、城市学院和监狱。”奇怪的是，现代剔旧做法的最大变化之一是肯尼斯·道林本人帮助建立的东西：图书馆之间的在线交流。
You know, in an ideal world, you might want to have every book, but we just don't have the shelf space for every book, so you rely on somebody else's shelves to hold the book. Some libraries spell musty with an I and an E at the end instead of a Y, for misleading, ugly, superseded, trivial, irrelevant, or elsewhere. Like if a copy of the book is at another library nearby. Jason Gibbs at the SFPL and Sharon McKen, Keller, across the bay at the Oakland Public Library, can now communicate with each other instantly
“你知道，在理想的世界里，你可能想拥有每一本书，但我们就是没有存放每一本书的书架空间，所以你依赖别人的书架来存放书。”有些图书馆把MUSTY的Y换成了I和E，代表误导、丑陋、被取代、琐碎、无关或在别处（Elsewhere）。比如如果这本书的副本在附近的其他图书馆。旧金山公共图书馆的杰森·吉布斯和海湾对面的奥克兰公共图书馆的莎伦·麦凯勒现在可以立即沟通，
so they can share book space and make different volumes available to readers in both cities. And this has huge implications for what gets weeded and why. In this respect, Kenneth Dallin was very right. He certainly failed in terms of managing the collection, but he succeeded to the extent of bringing us into the wider network of libraries online. And yet still, because of Baker's 1996 lawsuit, the San Francisco Public Library has kept the old card catalog. They are legally required to. The card catalog was a way of holding onto the memory of a quarter of a million books that they'd gotten rid of.
这样他们就可以共享书籍空间，并使不同的卷册可供两个城市的读者使用。这对剔旧的内容和原因有着巨大的影响。在这方面，肯尼斯·道林是非常正确的。他在管理馆藏方面确实失败了，但他成功地将我们带入了更广泛的在线图书馆网络。然而，由于贝克1996年的诉讼，旧金山公共图书馆保留了旧卡片目录。法律要求他们这样做。卡片目录是一种保留他们处理掉的二十五万本书记忆的方式。
Those cabinets full of Carnes are still there in storage. Practically barricaded in by all kinds of other supplies, but I'll go down and visit it every now and then. Just to say hi? Yeah, well, just to know it's there. After this weeding debacle, Nicholson Baker became even more vested in philosophies and practices of archiving and went on to publish a book that touched on all this called Double Fold. It looks at these events in the much broader context of the digitization of libraries. And this book is now commonly assigned in master's programs in library science.
“那些装满卡片的柜子仍然在仓库里。实际上被各种其他用品封锁了，但我偶尔会下去看看。”“只是为了打个招呼？”“是的，嗯，只是为了知道它还在那里。”在这次剔旧惨败后，尼科尔森·贝克对归档的哲学和实践变得更加投入，并出版了一本涉及所有这些的书，名为《双重折叠》（Double Fold）。它在数字化图书馆的更广泛背景下审视了这些事件。这本书现在通常被图书馆学硕士课程指定为必读书目。
We read the Nicholson Baker book in library school. That's Sharon McKellar again from the Oakland Public Library. She says that the debacle at the San Francisco Public Library has become a case study about weeding. why we do weed and how we should weed and what could be done, you know, how to do it well and what to avoid and all that kind of stuff. And when it's done well with care and consideration, weeding isn't so bad at all.
“我们在图书馆学校读过尼科尔森·贝克的书。”那是奥克兰公共图书馆的莎伦·麦凯勒。她说，旧金山公共图书馆的惨败已经成为剔旧的案例研究。为什么我们要剔旧，我们应该如何剔旧，以及可以做什么，你知道，如何做好它，以及要避免什么等等。当它被小心谨慎地做好时，剔旧一点也不坏。
For me, weeding is fun. It's a chance to really touch the books and see how they're doing and see what people are interested in. That's what all this comes down to. It's what people are interested in. Weeding isn't just about what to cut. It's also about what to keep. It's about what the public wants to read.
“对我来说，剔旧很有趣。这是一个真正接触书籍、看看它们状况如何、看看人们对什么感兴趣的机会。”这就是这一切的归结。这是人们感兴趣的东西。剔旧不仅仅是关于剪掉什么。它也关于保留什么。它关于公众想读什么。
Your voice does matter, and we're maintaining a collection for the public and for the people who use it. And so every time you check out a book from the library, you are casting a vote to your local librarian roving the stacks to keep this title in circulation for everyone to read. That story originally aired in 2019. It was reported by Pierce Gelley and edited by Avery Truffleman, original tech production by Shreif Yous, remixed by Martin Gonzalez. Ken Dallin did not respond to our interview requests, but a huge thanks to the librarians who helped us with context and background, especially Shelley Coching and Mindy Lenetzky, both from the San Francisco Public Library. Thanks as well to Orrin Rodolfsky. After the break, the dictionary in reverse.
“你的声音确实很重要，我们正在为公众和使用它的人维护一个馆藏。”所以每次你从图书馆借出一本书，你都在向你的当地馆员投出一票，让他们在书库中巡视，将这个书名保留在流通中，供所有人阅读。那个故事最初于2019年播出。由皮尔斯·格利报道，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼编辑，原始技术制作由谢里夫·尤斯完成，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。肯·道林没有回应我们的采访请求，但非常感谢帮助我们提供背景和背景信息的馆员，特别是旧金山公共图书馆的谢莉·科钦和明迪·莱内茨基。也感谢奥林·罗多尔夫斯基。休息后，反向字典。
Stay with us. Finding books in the library is now pretty simple. You can go up to a computer, you type in the name of the book or the author. The computer will tell you where you can find it in the stacks, if it's checked out or not, how many holds there are, whether branches might have copies. But before computers, there were card catalogs, massive filing cabinets of index cards. For every book, librarians would have to make a card for the drawers that were sorted by title. and then another card for the drawers that were sorted by author.
请继续收听。在图书馆找书现在很简单。你可以走到电脑前，输入书名或作者。电脑会告诉你可以在书库的哪里找到它，它是否被借出，有多少人预约，其他分馆是否有副本。但在电脑出现之前，有卡片目录，那是装满索引卡的大型文件柜。对于每一本书，馆员都必须为按书名排序的抽屉制作一张卡片，然后为按作者排序的抽屉制作另一张卡片。
And for non-fiction books, a couple more cards for the drawers that were sorted by subject. Every time you wanted to sort the information in a new way, you needed to create an entirely new index. Our senior editor, Delaney Hall, has a story about a particularly niche sorting method. Why don't you start with who you are, actually? Okay, yeah. So I am Delaney Hall, and I am a producer and senior editor on staff. All right. So what is your story today? Well, first I'm going to introduce you to Peter Sokolowski.
对于非虚构类书籍，还要为按主题排序的抽屉多做几张卡片。每次你想以新的方式对信息进行排序时，都需要创建一个全新的索引。我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔有一个关于一种特别小众的排序方法的故事。“你为什么不先介绍一下你自己？”“好的，是的。我是德莱尼·霍尔，我是员工制作人和高级编辑。”“好的。那么你今天的故事是什么？”“嗯，首先我要向你介绍彼得·索科洛夫斯基。”
And my levels are okay? Okay, so I'm not too loud. I'm not pop. I try to not pop my peas, but I get excited. I'll try not to talk too fast. And the stuff that Peter gets really excited about, the stuff that makes him pop his peas and talk really fast, is language. Because he's the editor at large at Miriam Webster, and he's a lexicographer. Lexicographer is a person who compiles and edits dictionaries.
“我的音量还可以吗？好的，所以我不会太大声。我没有爆破音。我尽量不让我的P音爆破，但我很兴奋。我会尽量不说话太快。”彼得真正感到兴奋的事情，那些让他爆破P音并说话很快的事情，是语言。因为他是梅里亚姆-韦伯斯特词典的特约编辑，也是一位词典编纂者。词典编纂者是编写和编辑词典的人。
That's the old definition. The great Samuel Johnson, the lexicographer in London in the mid-18th century, very famously defined a lexicographer as a harmless drudge. And Peter actually said that they use that term affectionately now as like a kind of badge of honor. They like to be called harmless drudges. So don't worry about insulting them if you want to use that term. So what is a harmless drudge like Peter do all day at Miriam Webster?
那是旧定义。伟大的塞缪尔·约翰逊，18世纪中叶伦敦的词典编纂者，非常著名地将词典编纂者定义为“无害的苦力”。彼得实际上说，他们现在亲切地使用这个词，作为一种荣誉勋章。他们喜欢被称为“无害的苦力”。所以如果你想用这个词，不用担心会冒犯他们。那么像彼得这样的无害苦力在梅里亚姆-韦伯斯特整天做什么呢？
Well, from his description, it sounds like they work in an office that is very, very quiet, silent, basically. And it's filled with these massive steel filing cabinets. And I've kind of been imagining it like that scene in Raiders of the Lost Ark at the end where the man is pushing that crate through a huge warehouse. But instead of stacks of enormous crates, it's filled with. metal filing cabinets and those metal filing cabinets are filled with index cards as far as i know it's the largest body of collected evidence of any language in the world it's 15 or 16 million index cards uh with a word in use that is to say in context with its full bibliography so we know who wrote it and where it was published and when it was published and so that is the work of lexicographers
嗯，从他的描述来看，听起来他们在办公室工作，那里非常、非常安静，基本上是静音的。而且它装满了这些巨大的钢制文件柜。我有点把它想象成《夺宝奇兵》结尾的那一幕，那个人把板条箱推过一个巨大的仓库。但不是堆积如山的巨大板条箱，而是装满了金属文件柜，那些金属文件柜里装满了索引卡。“据我所知，这是世界上任何语言中最大的收集证据库。它有15或1600万张索引卡，上面有正在使用的词，也就是说，在上下文中，带有完整的书目，所以我们知道是谁写的，在哪里出版的，什么时候出版的，这就是词典编纂者的工作。”
They're the keepers of that word history. And for a long time, before computers came along, this is how they did it with these massive systems of filing cabinets. There's the file for the phonetician, for the pronunciation editor. There's the file for our dating editors who do the etymological dating. So it's a place full of file cabinets. But this isn't actually a story about how the Miriam Webster offices are filled with filing cabinets. It's not, okay. No, it's not.
他们是那个词汇历史的守护者。很长一段时间，在电脑出现之前，他们就是这样做的，用这些庞大的文件柜系统。“有语音学家的文件，有发音编辑的文件。有我们负责词源年代测定的年代编辑的文件。”所以这是一个装满文件柜的地方。但这实际上不是一个关于梅里亚姆-韦伯斯特办公室如何装满文件柜的故事。“不是吗，好的。”“不，不是。”
It's a story about one special filing cabinet in their office. Okay, so here's where it gets really interesting. So one day, Peter was wandering through these endless rows of filing cabinets, and he came across this one. And one of them simply said backward index on it. And so he opens up the cabinet that says backward index. And I realized what it was, which was, you know, all of the headwords of the Underbridge Dictionary,
这是一个关于他们办公室里一个特殊文件柜的故事。好吧，有趣的地方来了。有一天，彼得在这些一排排无尽的文件柜中漫步，他偶然发现了这一个。其中一个柜子上简单地写着“反向索引”。于是他打开了写着“反向索引”的柜子。我意识到那是什么，你知道，那是《韦氏大词典》所有的词条，
some 315,000 separate index cards with only one word on them, and it was a headword typed backwards. And so the head word is the entry in the dictionary? That's the first word. That's the word in question. Right. Yeah, exactly. So this index is like imagine all the words in the dictionary, but typed backwards and then organized alphabetically. Okay.
大约315,000张独立的索引卡片，每张卡片上只有一个词，而且是把词条倒着拼写的。那么词条就是字典里的条目吗？那是第一个词。就是我们要讨论的那个词。对。是的，没错。所以这个索引就像是想象一下字典里的所有词，但是倒着拼写，然后按字母顺序排列。好的。
Okay. So why would you do that? Yeah. that is the question because the utility of it is not immediately obvious, at least not to non-lexicographers like you and me. But Peter, the harmless dredge, he kind of got it. Lexicography is an extreme sport. This is a kind of a radical practice of collection and of archiving. And so to a certain degree, this is maybe the weirdest example of that kind of archiving. But it made a kind of sense to me. And to really understand why it makes any kind of
好的。那为什么要那样做呢？是的，这就是问题所在，因为它的用途并不显而易见，至少对于像你我这样的非词典编纂者来说是这样。但是彼得，那个无害的挖掘者，他多少理解了。词典编纂是一项极限运动。这是一种激进的收集和归档实践。所以在某种程度上，这可能是那种归档方式中最奇怪的例子。但这对我来说确实有某种意义。要真正理解为什么它有某种
sense, you have to think back to when lexicographers first started compiling the backward index, which was in the 1930s, it turns out, which was a time before computers and all of the search possibilities that they allow. In the pre-digital era, how else could we have known that there are, for example, 500 words in the dictionary, the end in ology? And yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you're getting it. That's because with a regular dictionary, just organized in a regular alphabetical way, a word like ecology would not appear next to a word like technology because one starts with E and one starts with T. I got it. Okay, so with a backward index, all the words that end in ology, for example, would be grouped together.
意义，你必须回想一下词典编纂者最初开始编制反向索引的时候，那是在20世纪30年代，事实证明，那是在计算机和它们所允许的所有搜索可能性出现之前的时代。在前数字时代，我们还能怎么知道，例如，字典里有500个以“ology”结尾的词呢？是的。是的。是的，你明白了。这是因为用普通的字典，只是按常规的字母顺序排列，像“ecology”（生态学）这样的词就不会出现在像“technology”（技术）这样的词旁边，因为一个以E开头，一个以T开头。我明白了。好的，所以有了反向索引，所有以“ology”结尾的词，例如，就会被归在一起。
Yeah, so you couldn't actually look up ology words. You would look up Y, G. E-O-L-O words. But in doing that, you would find them. Exactly. Yeah, yeah. So cool. Kind of ingenious.
是的，所以你实际上无法查找“ology”词汇。你会查找Y、G、E-O-L-O开头的词。但这样做，你就能找到它们。没错。是的，是的。太酷了。真是一种天才的做法。
And there are actually a lot of other examples of why this is useful. There was no way that they could know, for example, how many words in English are made with the compound like, like, you know, block like, clock like, clock like. Or how many open compounds, that is to say two word phrases that use pomperseys. that use pony, so Highland Pony, Shetland Pony, Welsh Pony, that kind of thing. And then it gets a little deeper, those words that are related morphologically, like ethological, lithological, ornithological, you know, things that end in that particular sequence of letters. And then just basic rhyming sequences, steepy, weepy, sweepy, 40, shorty, snorty.
实际上还有很多其他例子说明为什么这很有用。他们无法知道，例如，英语中有多少词是由像“like”这样的复合词构成的，比如“block like”、“clock like”。或者有多少开放式复合词，也就是说使用“pony”的双词短语，比如“Highland Pony”（高地矮种马）、“Shetland Pony”（设得兰矮种马）、“Welsh Pony”（威尔士矮种马）等等。然后更深入一点，那些在形态上相关的词，比如“ethological”（行为学的）、“lithological”（岩性的）、“ornithological”（鸟类学的），你知道，以特定字母序列结尾的词。还有就是基本的押韵序列，“steepy”、“weepy”、“sweepy”、“40”、“shorty”、“snorty”。
And in fact, this backward index was instrumental in the creation of Miriam Webster's first rhyming dictionary. Oh yeah. I have one of those. Oh yeah, yeah. They're still, they're very popular. They're really, really good. So by reading words backwards, you can start to see new kinds of patterns like the ology pattern or the logical pattern or just rhyming patterns. That's so cool. The kind of lexical detail that we can get into by looking at the language backwards does sort of illuminate our knowledge of the language as we read it in a normal way. So you said it came from the 1930s before there were computers. But does Peter know anything about who actually made this mysterious filing cabinet? Yeah. So after he discovered it, he started doing some research. And exactly
事实上，这个反向索引在韦氏词典第一本押韵词典的创作中起到了关键作用。哦，是的。我有一本。哦，是的，是的。它们仍然非常受欢迎。它们真的非常好。所以通过倒着读单词，你可以开始看到新的模式，比如“ology”模式或“logical”模式，或者仅仅是押韵模式。太酷了。通过倒着看语言所能获得的词汇细节，确实照亮了我们以正常方式阅读语言时的知识。所以你说它来自20世纪30年代，在计算机出现之前。但彼得知道是谁制作了这个神秘的文件柜吗？是的。在他发现它之后，他开始做一些研究。而究竟
who invented it is still a bit of a mystery. He figured out that it dates back to the 1930s and there's some evidence that lexicographers worked on it up until the 1970s. So he knows how long it was actively being compiled. And he also found out that the project was, a kind of favorite pet project of this one editor named Philip Gove. He edited Webster's third unabridged dictionary in the 1950s, and it sounds like he was very rigorous and rule-oriented. Who is sort of famous for his organizational skills and for making the dictionary apparatus, that is to say, the things that we use as kind of code in the dictionary,
是谁发明了它仍然是个谜。他发现它追溯到20世纪30年代，并且有一些证据表明词典编纂者一直工作到20世纪70年代。所以他知道它被积极编制了多久。他还发现这个项目是这位名叫菲利普·戈夫（Philip Gove）的编辑最喜欢的项目。他在20世纪50年代编辑了《韦氏第三版新国际大词典》，听起来他非常严谨且注重规则。他因其组织能力和制作字典工具而闻名，也就是说，我们在字典中用作代码的东西，
Things like, you know, what does a bold-faced colon mean? What does a light-faced, you know, italic semicolon mean? When can we use commas? There's a rule for everything. And so it was really Gove who systematized all of that. He made a rulebook for us, for the editors, that was followed to the T. It was really, really strict and very kind of innovative in its way. And also kind of proto-digital, because when we finally did digitize that dictionary,
比如，你知道，粗体的冒号是什么意思？细体的斜体分号是什么意思？我们什么时候可以使用逗号？每件事都有规则。所以确实是戈夫系统化了所有这些。他为我们编辑制定了一本规则手册，被严格遵守。它确实非常严格，而且在当时非常具有创新性。而且也算是一种原始数字化的东西，因为当我们最终将那本字典数字化时，
we recognized how very regular the application. apparatus was. So Gove, from Peter's description, it seems like he thought about the dictionary with the logic of a computer programmer, but before computers were a thing. And now that computers are a thing, I mean, you mentioned the backward index sort of fell out in the 1970s, which makes tons of sense. The computers must have really changed the way lexicographers or the dictionary really works. Yeah, totally. I mean, for one thing, they have made the old school backwards index, totally obsolete. On the Miriam Webster website, there's an advanced search function where you can type in
我们认识到这个应用工具是多么的规范。所以戈夫，从彼得的描述来看，他似乎是用计算机程序员的逻辑来思考字典，但在计算机出现之前。现在计算机已经普及了，我的意思是，你提到反向索引在20世纪70年代左右被淘汰了，这非常有道理。计算机一定彻底改变了词典编纂者或字典的工作方式。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，首先，它们使老式的反向索引完全过时了。在韦氏词典网站上，有一个高级搜索功能，你可以输入
ology or phobia. And you don't have to spell it backwards. No, you don't have to spell it backwards. It pulls up all the words that end with ology or phobia. So easy. We have it so easy. We really do. We really do.
“ology”或“phobia”。你不需要倒着拼写它。不，你不需要倒着拼写。它会调出所有以“ology”或“phobia”结尾的词。太容易了。我们现在太轻松了。我们确实如此。我们确实如此。
And then computers have also allowed lexicographers like Peter to see other kinds of interesting patterns. For example. Well, my favorite that we talked about in this interview is this function on Miriam Webster's website, which is called Time Traveler. By which you can reorder the dictionary in chronological order as opposed to alphabetical order, because ultimately alphabetical order is random. It's arbitrary. But chronological order isn't because English develops in a very particular way. All the words, for example, about train travel and train tracks. and coal and engines, they all come at a certain time,
而且计算机也让像彼得这样的词典编纂者能够看到其他有趣的模式。例如。嗯，我在这次采访中谈到的我最喜欢的是韦氏词典网站上的这个功能，叫做“时间旅行者”。通过它，你可以按时间顺序而不是字母顺序重新排列字典，因为归根结底，字母顺序是随机的。它是任意的。但时间顺序不是，因为英语的发展方式非常特殊。例如，所有关于火车旅行和铁轨、煤炭和引擎的词，它们都在特定的时间出现，
all words that have to do with repeating firearms. They all come at a certain time. You know, the words that entered the language regarding the law that are derived from French, they all come in at a similar time. So reorganizing the dictionary in a digital way turns out to be a way to sort of turn the dictionary into a three-dimensional search. Rather than just simply a list, we can go in greater depth.
所有与连发枪支有关的词。它们都在特定的时间出现。你知道，那些源自法语的关于法律的词汇进入语言，它们都在相似的时间进入。所以以数字方式重新组织字典，结果变成了一种将字典变成三维搜索的方法。而不是仅仅是一个列表，我们可以进行更深入的探索。
That's amazing. Isn't that fascinating? It's so cool. I love the idea of the time traveler. Yeah, it's such a good way to order knowledge in a certain way. And it's sort of like the backwards index was an early pre-digital attempt at achieving that kind of three-dimensional search. Right, right. That's so cool.
太神奇了。这不迷人吗？太酷了。我喜欢“时间旅行者”这个想法。是的，这是一种以某种方式整理知识的好方法。这有点像反向索引是早期实现那种三维搜索的预数字化尝试。对，对。太酷了。
Well, thanks. Yeah, thank you. That was senior editor Delaney Hall from our 2018 mini-stories. 99% Invisible was produced and remitored. This Weeks this week by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube,
好的，谢谢。是的，谢谢你。那是来自我们2018年迷你故事的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。《99%隐形》由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）制作和重新编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。凯西·2（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube），
Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lajemadon, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora Building, and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites,
杰森·德里昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉杰马顿（Lajemadon）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。99%的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区，在潘多拉大厦，美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，
including Blue Sky as well as your own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
包括Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器。那里有一个链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。